when I was a little girl my mom would
hold each of my hands and lift me up as
the waves crashed over her feet and as I
grew up on the Jersey Shore and was big
enough to stand on my own there was no
water too cold or waves too rough to
keep me from swimming and to this day
the sound of waves crashing brings a
calm to my being it sounds like home
because like billions of people around
the world I grew up near a Coast sadly
we are changing our coasts in dangerous
ways our coasts are dynamic spaces they
divide the world in which we live from
the massive expanse of the ocean here in
California our coasts are rocky and
clift think half moon bay and along
Route one but for many miles of the
world's coastlines our water blends in
to land in a special ecosystem known as
wetlands so what are wetlands here water
covers soil for most of the year and
depending on where you're from they go
by many names they are mangroves and
marshes they are swamps and sloughs
today I'll try to stick to wetlands for
short and I want to show you that these
wetlands hold far more economic and
environmental power than you think
wetlands protect us from the ocean by
buffering against storms and they
protect the ocean from us by filtering
out our pollution and so now you're
thinking wetlands sound great what's the
problem over the past century our
wetlands have disappeared at an alarming
rate nearly half of the world's wetlands
are already gone in the US that's 220
million acres here in the Bay Area we
filled in and developed on top of
eighty-five percent of our historic
wetlands in other places we dredged our
wetlands physically removing them
to create more water for fishing and
shipping or we damned upstream and we
starved our wetlands of the dirt and
silt they need to survive so how do we
fix this I'm here to convince you that
whenever possible we must not develop or
replace our wetlands and we need to get
creative about restoring the wetlands
we've already lost to show you let me
share a couple stories of the power of a
salt marsh was the summer of two
thousand twelve and I was living on the
chesapeake bay on the eastern shore of
virginia one morning I was awoken by a
very particular rotting smell imagine
the worst smell you can fathom imagine
that that smell permeates your home the
air so I walked to the beach just a
couple hundred yards from my home and as
I approached the water that smell only
got stronger when I finally reach the
bay there was no sand in sight only dead
fish as far as I can see in any
direction it was a fish kill this
horrible event became a shockingly
regular part of life when I lived on the
Chesapeake Bay so let's start with the
science farmers apply fertilizer to
their fields to increase production
while most of this fertilizer is used by
those plants some of it washes into
nearby streams and eventually into bays
in the ocean just like crops
phytoplankton the microscopic plants
living in the water thrive on this new
nutrients these phytoplankton grow so
fast that they trigger a change that
leads to the loss of oxygen in
widespread areas of water just like us
fish breathe oxygen when fish reach
these hypoxic zones areas without oxygen
they die in large numbers and wash up on
shore this is a crisis in coastal
communities it's not just an ecological
blow this is an economic disaster for
all of the fishers who rely on these
fish for their income
but what is this fertilized water never
reach the ocean what if instead this
fertilized water went into wetlands and
the plants they're used all of the
nutrients and left none for the
phytoplankton for many years our coastal
wetlands acted as this natural filter
between land and water they absorbed the
nutrients and play this critical role in
our coastal communities sadly with the
loss of our wetlands these hypoxic zones
cover large regions of our world's most
fertile fishing grounds including much
of the Gulf of Mexico today yet this is
a story of hope in the Chesapeake Bay we
have seen fish kills decrease from 50s
kills each year from hypoxia in the 80s
to just 10 today with a management plan
our coasts are resilient when given a
chance so let's reimagine communities
where fishers do not suffer at the hands
of farmers and now you know the power of
a wetland to protect our ocean let's
talk about the power of a wetland to
protect you climate change has
transformed what it means to live on our
coasts flooding is already the most
common natural disaster in the US and is
only becoming more common as sea levels
rise and storms increase in frequency
and intensity those of us who live and
work on the coast are at the most risk
in the 20th century the gulf coast of
the US was dredged for expanded ports
and new shipping lanes with the belief
that wetlands held little value except
breeding ground for mosquitoes we lost
an average of thirty four square miles
each year that's 16,000 football fields
it's bigger than Palo Alto every year
tragically we were reminded of the true
value of our wetlands when Hurricane
Katrina hit the city of New Orleans in
2005
while Katrina was dangerous with or
without wetlands the absence of the
natural defense led to higher water
levels and more flooding and likely more
property damage and lives lost in an
attempt to mitigate these risks we have
hardened our coasts a process of
replacing the natural defenses of
marshes and sea grasses with sea walls
and levees to separate land and sea
concrete walls look strong but with one
major storm event like Katrina these
walls are breached and destroyed taking
with them the land they were meant to
protect nothing can guarantee safety or
permanence in the face of Mother Nature
yet natural defenses can provide a
sustainable solution to questions of
coastal storm protection wetlands may
not seem as strong as concrete but
researchers found that the presence of
mangroves in Florida reduced waves
caused by wind by 75 percent during a
storm surge for every mile width of
mangrove there was a decrease of nearly
two and a half feet of water level rise
for people of the Gulf Coast and for
people of coast around the world
wetlands really can mean the difference
between life and death so now what today
nearly half of the world's population
lives within 100 miles of a Coast eight
of the world's 10 largest cities sit
directly on the sea we must protect our
coastal wetlands to protect our coastal
communities thankfully humans are
brilliant adaptable creatures and guess
what wetlands are resilient too and look
I'm not saying we never develop wetlands
I'm saying when we need to make this
difficult decision we consider the true
value of all wetlands provide us and get
creative about replacing all of the
natural defenses we lose because if we
decide to protect our coastal
communities by restoring
and maintaining wetlands our
intervention will turn the tide so
imagine a future where we protect our
coasts in the face of storms and we
protect our ocean against negligence on
land imagine a future where I have a
coast to enjoy the waves with my
daughter because if we protect our
coastal wetlands they protect us and our
coasts tell a story of hope if only we
choose to listen thank you